Avengers infinity war came and went it
was an amazing movie in which we saw the
Avengers go up against the mad Titan
Thanos and try to stop him from
collecting all the Infinity stones quick
spoiler alert if you have not seen
Avengers infinity war but plan on seeing
it
skip ahead to 50 seconds in this video
The Avengers fought with everything they
had but in the end it was not enough to
stop Thanos the mad Titan succeeded in
collecting all of the Infinity stones
and succeeded in his snap effectively
wiping out half of the universe so you
watched all the movies in the MCU
learned a little bit about the Infinity
stones along the way and then watched
Thanos use them all to wipe out half of
the universe Wow and now you're
wondering what exactly is the history of
the Infinity stones and where did they
come from don't worry I've got you
covered
I'll be doing a video on each of the
Infinity stones talking about their
origin and history and in this video
we're going to talk about the first
Infinity stone to ever appear in the
comics and ironically enough it's the
soul stone quick reminder that I'm doing
an infinity war blu-ray giveaway if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero it's ironic
that the soul stone was the first to
appear in the comics because the soul
stone was the last to appear in the MCU
and was kept a huge mystery up until
Avengers infinity war and according to
Steffi Feldman at Marvel the soul stone
was the inspiration for all the rest
quick note in the comics the Infinity
stones were actually called the infinity
gems eons ago the six gems were an
essential part of an ancient entity
called Nemesis who was the only sentient
being in the universe ultimately nimis
would choose to destroy itself rather
than live alone being the only sentient
being in the universe and out of its
destruction came to six Infinity gems
the six key building blocks of the
universe mind reality power space-time
and soul the six gems were scattered
across the universe that is until it was
discovered that if you combined all the
stones and used them
together the wielder could essentially
shape the cosmos until whatever they
wanted this type of power was very
attractive to some people
Thanos being one of the main ones what's
her timeline no telling he has the power
and space stones that already makes him
the strongest creature in the whole
universe the first appearance of an
infinity gym came in 1972 in Marvel
premiere number one when the High
Evolutionary gifted the soul gym to Adam
warlock Adam wood used the powers of the
soul gym to do good and then in Marvel
team-up number 55 a big secret was let
out there is more than one infinity gym
Adam warlock and spider-man took on the
stranger who had his own infinity gym
and sought others fighting on a distant
moon they were helped by the gardener
who also had his own infinity gym all
six Infinity gyms were then seen in
Avengers annual number seven where their
collective power would tried to be used
for the first time by none other than
vanos and then in 1991 the Infinity
Gauntlet finally came into play in the
Infinity Gauntlet series this series
where Thanos successfully collected all
of the Infinity stones in an attempt to
impress mistress death set up the
Infinity stones as some of the most
powerful destructive and sought-after
items in the Marvel Universe so powerful
and sought-after that even the last ten
years of the MCU have all been leading
up to Avengers infinity war where we
would see Thea nose try to collect the
Infinity stones on-screen now we wait
with excitement and anticipation for
Avengers 4 so that's it for the history
of the soul gym be sure to subscribe to
my channel with the notifications turned
on so you can get notified when I do the
next video on the next Infinity stone
and another reminder about the Infinity
Ward blu-ray giveaway I'm doing all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]